Well, I think the fact that the three of us are standing here...
...talking about a peaceful transfer of power...
...speaks to the institutional integrity of our country.
So, this is an unusual thing.
We are both trying to come back to normalcy,...
...deal with totally abnormal challenges, and do what we do best,...
...which is try to make a more perfect union.
That's an exciting time.
We've got to not just listen to folks we agree with, but listen to folks we don't.
And one of my fondest memories of the inauguration...
...was the grace and generosity that President Bush showed me...
...and Laura Bush showed Michelle.
And it was a reminder that we can have fierce disagreements...
...and yet recognize each other's common humanity...
...and that, as Americans, we have more in common than what separates us.
I think if Americans would love their neighbor...
...like they would love to be loved themselves,...
...a lot of the division in our society would end.